le hellfest c'est ça ou bien ça c'est un
festival de musiques dites extrêmes hard
rock death metal punk le rendez-vous des
métallos du monde entier avec tous les
clichés satanistes qui vit
tout commence en 2006 à trois quarts
d'heure de nantes à clisson clisson un
village plutôt bourgeois mais l'idée de
l fest festival de l'enfer en français
ça n'inquiète personne il en faut pour
tous les goûts il ya des jeunes ya des
gens qui aiment bien genre de musique
honnêtement je ne savais même pas qu'il
y avait un concert le hellfest est un
succès il revient chaque année 2 qui ne
réjouit pas d'église en 2008
les noms des groupes d'annoncés à gaz
comme whiting price en français
pourriture de christ le christ pour moi
c'est quelqu'un d'important c'est un ami
c'est celui à qui j'ai donné ma vie
c'est vrai pour tous les chrétiens et je
me sens touchés humiliés choqué dans ma
foi lorsque j'entends ces mots là c'est
bien connu le métalleux et satanique ou
pas en 2009 après ça certains cherchent
un peu de quiétude
tu crois en jésus après bon le paradis
l'enfer je suis fais ici pour encore
j'écoute du métal j'écoute du slayer
pourtant qui sont certes à nick et moi
je rangeais une voie là et le hellfest
est aussi un sujet de querelle politique
en 2010 christine boutin accuse un
festival qui promeut et véhicule la
culture de la mort
il n'en fallait pas plus pour énerver
patrick roy député ps est fan de méthane
alors monsieur le ministre
j'attends bravo et d'actions allant sur
ses propos qui rappellent les heures
sombres de l'histoire européenne vous
emplit si vous êtes pour la diversité
culturelle
êtes vous prêt à le voter le sort des
musiques comme le rock métal non son
financement
merci la parole au fond christianisme
des hellfest ne sont pas incompatibles
la preuve en 2010 avec un prêtre
spécialiste du méthane
c'est en leader d'amal dan ya du banc
métal mais en revanche à des grands
leaders comme cradle par exemple morbid
angel d'autres qui font des tournées
européennes au mondial et en revanche
ils font que du métal qui sont quand
même une opposition assez anti chrétiens
après tout le hellfest ne serait-il pas
l'occasion de réfléchir à la mort c'est
la ville de se faire traiter en 2017 en
visibilité au festival d'abord de la
mort sous un angle comme ça moi j'aime
bien ça me fait moins fort la latte en
défaut chemin en tchat
malgré mes doigts qui sont pas vos ouais
c'est bon bon allez ça suffit
[Applaudissements]
et c'est vraiment une chorale